monsieur le ministre il y a 4 ans
avec Peugeot et Renault la France
disposait de constructeurs automobiles
de dimension mondiale ayant en commun un
actionnaire l'État français qui est un
actionnaire d'influence
depuis l'un a trouvé la voie de la
croissance en acceptant d'être dilué
dans le groupe Fiat Chrysler groupe
italo-américain et l'autre est passé de
la première place mondiale à celle de
plus petit constructeur automobile
européen
hier le directeur général de Renault a
annoncé le troisième volet de son plan
pour cette entreprise ce plan qui
consiste à scinder en deux cette
entreprise et notamment avec de nouveaux
partenaires l'un chinois l'autre
saoudien
dans le même temps le directeur général
de Nissan en début de semaine dans la
presse économique revendiquée la
nécessité de rééquilibrer l'alliance
avec Renault
comme beaucoup de Français je
m'interroge et je m'étonne ce qui semble
être la passivité du gouvernement
français
vis-à-vis de ses partenaires dans la
mesure où
on ne comprend pas pourquoi 4 ans après
la crise suscitée par l'incarcération de
l'ancien directeur général de Renault
d'ailleurs sans preuve probante jusqu'à
ce jour le gouvernement accepte
éventuellement cette remise en cause je
voudrais savoir si il s'agit d'un
rééquilibrage volontaire ou si vous
allez accepter le démantèlement de cette
alliance